RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, we're live.
Hey, welcome to this
week's Android
Developer Office Hours.
I'm joined here in London by--
MATT GAUNT: Matt Gaunt.
CHRIS BANES: Chris Banes.
NICK BUTCHER: Nick Butcher.
RICH HYNDMAN: And I'm Rich
Hyndman, which I should have
said up front.
We've already got--
I think it's--
David and Wiebe have joined
us in the Hangout.
Hi, guys.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Hello.
DAVID: Hi.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey.
As usual, we'll be discussing
Android development topics.
And also as usual, we won't be
discussing roadmaps, future
things, unreleased--
or unannounced--
I guess roadmaps.
I don't know.
I said the word roadmaps
twice.
Thank you for all the
questions in the
moderator this week.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: We do have one.
So maybe we'll just get the--
ah, two actually.
We'll get those out of
the way up front.
And then just go into some
kind of discussion.
And hopefully some more people
will join us and keep the
content going throughout.
Oh.
OK, what was our one
moderator question?
Two, sorry.
CHRIS BANES: We had why was the
US office hours stopped?
And is it coming back?
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, has
it been stopped?
Yes.
Is it gone for good?
I think so.
The US team played with
the office hours
format for a while.
And they decided to move on to
other formats, like This Week
and Android.
CHRIS BANES: Maybe it was a
time zone thing, but they
weren't getting too
many viewers.
There seemed lots of people
come into this time slot.
And not so much for
that time slot.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's funny we
used to call this Android
Developer Office Hours EMEA.
Maybe we still do.
But we've been looking at the
statistics on YouTube, more
than 50% of the viewers are
actually from the US.
So maybe it's just because they
can get up in the morning
and watch it before they
go to work, or I don't
know what it is.
CHRIS BANES: So where
are you, David?
DAVID: I'm in North Carolina.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, hey.
There we go.
Except the sample size.
RICH HYNDMAN: Is that where
The Fresh Prince was from?
NICK BUTCHER: Philadelphia?
RICH HYNDMAN: Philadelphia?
Oh, yeah.
I'm sure that's the song.
CHRIS BANES: They
can't hear this.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
Well, thanks for joining us.
Well, let's take one
from the floor.
Does anyone in the Hangout
have a question for us?
And hello, Amit.
Thanks for joining as well.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Yeah,
I have a question.
Chris, we discussed last time
you can use Wi-Fi Direct as a
way of [INAUDIBLE].
Do you know, what's the impact
for the mobile battery?
Or the device you're
trying to pair?
RICH HYNDMAN: I don't off
the top of my head.
I haven't used the
API much myself.
So I can't comment on battery
life and that kind of stuff.
I don't know.
I imagine it's better
than Bluetooth.
WIEBE ELSINGA: It is.
CHRIS BANES: But that's
only guessing.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hmm.
CHRIS BANES: Anyone
else got any
experience with Wi-Fi Direct?
RICH HYNDMAN: I don't.
But I mean, I have Wi-Fi
on the whole time
with my device, right?
I assume that turning Wi-Fi
Direct on-- at least in
discovery mode-- doesn't
really impact it.
MATT GAUNT: But is it in
more active stuff?
Because it's using all
the multicast stuff?
Because isn't it two different
chipsets at that point?
RICH HYNDMAN: Really?
MATT GAUNT: I don't know.
I know it has to be different
hardware.
So I'm wondering whether
it's one to receive?
There's one to actually--
RICH HYNDMAN: Maybe we need to
install Dr. Power, and turn on
Wi-Fi Direct, and see if it
uses much battery life.
I tell you what, I'll make
a note of this question.
CHRIS BANES: I imagine
it's better.
Just because the sheer amount
of bandwidth you have.
So the radio can go
to sleep quicker.
With Bluetooth you're limited
to 100K a second.
Whereas Wi-Fi Direct you're
in the megabits.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, you mean the
transmissions, they're quick
and you power down.
CHRIS BANES: Exactly.
NICK BUTCHER: That's
a good point.
CHRIS BANES: But
that's a guess.
NICK BUTCHER: I can honestly
say, the best thing to do is
probably benchmark it.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
WIEBE ELSINGA: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: What are you
using it for Wiebe?
WIEBE ELSINGA: I was looking for
a way to connect my Google
TV with my tablet and
my telephone.
But I can't use it for
my Google TV, because
it's 4.1 and up.
But I tried to connect my
telephone with my tablet to
see what it's doing.
CHRIS BANES: Maybe GCM.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Oh,
that's good.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, that'd
be quite good.
WIEBE ELSINGA: And there
goes the weekend again.
[LAUGHTER]
WIEBE ELSINGA: Nah, I'm using
Movile, and I'm looking into--
the other framework called?
All Join.
But they're really terrible.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh dear.
CHRIS BANES: All Join's
supposed to be
quite stable, but I've--
well, it looks quite good
from the website.
I don't know what the
actual code's like.
WIEBE ELSINGA: The Java Dock
and the implementation
examples are really terrible.
So a basic application.
It's a lot of work to do.
CHRIS BANES: Interesting.
WIEBE ELSINGA: OK, thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: See you, Wiebe.
CHRIS BANES: Cheers.
RICH HYNDMAN: Does anyone
else in the
Hangout have a question?
David?
DAVID: Well, no.
I was trying to look at--
I was just watching another
show last night.
And they were talking.
This application would allow you
to share bandwidth across
all your devices.
I'm trying to remember
the name of it now.
And I can't remember now.
It'll connect them
all together.
Well, they used to
use Wi-Fi Direct.
And they stopped that option.
It's only Bluetooth now.
So I think there might
be something to that.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Do you have
the link for the video?
DAVID: I'm trying to find it.
I was on another show and I
don't want to want to give
advertising and all that.
But I watched it.
RICH HYNDMAN: We don't mind.
DAVID: All About Android.
They were talking about it.
RICH HYNDMAN: That's
all right.
I hope you don't mind
this, I thought it
was one of your shows.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID: So yeah, yeah.
It was on a show about
Android only, but it
was All About Android.
And they were showing it now.
But it's only Bluetooth.
And if I find it I'll
send it up.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, great.
MATT GAUNT: Great.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey there,
Tyrone as well.
Welcome to the Hangout.
Do you have any questions
for us today?
Oh, I think you might
be muted there.
We can't hear you.
Hello?
TYRONE: Oh, hello.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh there we go.
Hey, hey.
TYRONE: Hey guys.
No questions.
I'm just kind of listening and
see if I can pick up some
pointers and stuff.
RICH HYNDMAN: Nice.
OK, well, nice to
have you here.
And Marty's also
just joined us.
Hey there Marty.
Looks like you must
be on a phone.
MARTY: Hey, yep.
I'm on a Nexus--
RICH HYNDMAN: I don't know,
something-- is that a Nexus 4,
would you say?
CHRIS BANES: Nexus
7, I thought.
MARTY: Nexus 7, yeah.
I'll just be listening in.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, hey.
CHRIS BANES: Are you the same
Marty who's just asked
question in the moderator?
MARTY: Yep, that's me.
CHRIS BANES: Do you want to go
ahead and ask it on video?
MARTY: Sure.
I was just asking if Photosphere
is open sourced?
And if it is, is there
an example
somewhere that I can review?
RICH HYNDMAN: Hmm.
CHRIS BANES: I didn't think
a camera app was--
RICH HYNDMAN: Good question.
I very much doubt that
Photosphere is open sourced.
We have some APIs now which
allow you to check if images
are Photospheres and that sort
of thing, and playback
Photospheres.
But I don't believe that
Photosphere itself is open
sourced, no.
MARTY: Is there some examples
for how to use those APIs?
NICK BUTCHER: They're part of
the Google Play services
library there, yeah.
For how to check if it's
Photosphere and then launch
the Photosphere viewer.
MARTY: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: What is it?
developer.google.com/android
and the Google Play services.
It's in there.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, check
Google Play services.
If you've got the support
library downloaded into you
SDK it will be on your filing
system already on you PC.
MARTY: Wonderful.
Thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: Under Extras.
So take a look in
there as well.
MARTY: OK.
CHRIS BANES: They're
coming in fast now.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, Have we
got some questions?
We have.
All right, again.
OK, I should open up the
moderator again.
CHRIS BANES: Any other live
questions in the room before
we plow on with the moderator?
I'm looking at you Paul.
RICH HYNDMAN: Paul?
When did Paul join?
Oh, yes.
PAUL: Hi guys.
No, nothing.
Or later on I'll come
up with something.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK BUTCHER: And Marty's put
his tablet down on the table.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: That's a really
nice ceiling he's
got going on there.
Let's see if we can figure
out where he is, do
like, CSI on him.
MATT GAUNT: Now he's got it.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE],
in half.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
MATT GAUNT: Right, let's
click on then.
All right, I'll ask one.
So Everland in Barcelona says,
all developers will be able to
replace comments placed
on Google Play?
If so, is there any
estimated date?
So I guess this would fall under
what we said at the top
of the show, that we're
not going to comment
about roadmap and stuff.
Like even if we did know a date,
when it was going to
roll out to everyone.
Then it would probably change,
and then we'd be wrong.
So I think the intentions
to this were
announced to everyone.
And it hasn't happened yet.
We've been expanding
the trial group.
But sit tight.
It will happen.
Yeah?
DAVID: Yeah I sure would love
to be able to just at least
talk to people that call me
names to see why they really
are having problems
with my apps.
Instead of just saying this
is not appropriate.
You know?
CHRIS BANES: Has the Google+
identity stuff helped at all?
You've been able to reach out
to them directly by that?
DAVID: No, I see they say
they're a Google user.
RICH HYNDMAN: To all
the ones that are
Google user are historic.
All new reviews that go in-- as
of about a month ago-- have
to have a Google+ identity
associated with them.
So you will be able to reach
them and at least find them on
Google+ and speak back to them
that way if you want.
The previous Google user ones,
if you search by date entered
instead of by relevance, then
you'll see that the top ones
should all have an
ID next to them.
Obviously the ones that people
have ticked This Was Useful to
Me filter to the top
in relevance.
But yeah, interesting to see.
NICK BUTCHER: So thanks for the
question, Everland, and
sorry we can't really commit to
dates and stuff like that.
But sit tight.
And we'll do the next caller.
RICH HYNDMAN: Is it possible to
publish an APK internally
within a company and not through
the Play Store that
uses the Google Maps API?
It would, yes.
[INAUDIBLE] that uses
the Google Maps API.
[INAUDIBLE]
Everyone dives on Marty.
OK.
So the first part--
I think as Wiebe
said as well--
the answer was yes.
Is it possible to
publish an APK
internally within a company?
Yes.
And you can do that inside
the Play Store.
If you're using a Google Apps
domain you get your own little
domain square inside the
application section of the
Play Store, and you can have
all your employees access
those applications.
So that's great.
But then it goes on to say not
in the Play Store, which is
slightly strange.
And then it goes on to
say that it uses
the Google Maps API?
So is the Google Maps API linked
to publishing through
the Play Store?
CHRIS BANES: No.
NICK BUTCHER: No.
MATT GAUNT: No.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
that's fine.
CHRIS BANES: Once the device has
got the Google experience,
they start Google Maps,
it should work.
RICH HYNDMAN: The only things
that are linked to publishing
through the Play Store are the
things that us the Play Store
client, which would be LVL,
in-app billing, yeah, and
having subscriptions.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Expansion
files?
RICH HYNDMAN: Expansion files,
thank you there, Wiebe, yep.
[INAUDIBLE].
That's probably it.
And the rest of the APIs that
you get available to you via
the API console are Google APIs
as opposed to Android
APIs or Play APIs.
And you can access all of
those via application.
Most of them will have certain
amounts of free quota.
And then you can either ask for
more or go into paid quota
for the separate Google
services.
So yes, you can use maps.
As long as the device you're
distributing it
on has Google maps.
OK?
CHRIS BANES: So next question.
Software bloke, from Milan has
asked if I add a birthday date
to my contacts, it would be
great if the date would sync
with G Calendar and set
notifications for that event.
It actually already does that.
So when you set your birthdate,
if you go onto
Google Calendar on the web, you
can add a calendar called
Contact Birthdays.
And it automatically shows
your calendar.
It doesn't do notifications
at the moment.
But it will show in
your calendar.
Because I've got that
one, and it's great.
RICH HYNDMAN: And it's just
there as an option?
CHRIS BANES: It's just
there as an option.
#protip.
Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: It's good.
RICH HYNDMAN: Might
do it right now.
calendar.google.com.
Good stuff Chris.
CHRIS BANES: I know.
It's awesome.
NICK BUTCHER: Sounds like it.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, next one?
CHRIS BANES: OK, so
Andre in Prague--
I've probably mispronounced
that-- asks if subscriptions
are going to be part of
the B3 billing API?
And at least, a time frame.
So again, see it at the top of
the show, we're not going to
be able to commit
to a time frame.
Have we definitely said
it's going to be part
of B3 billing API?
NICK BUTCHER: Yep.
CHRIS BANES: I think
everything is
going to the new structure.
So yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
Yeah, it says inside the
documentation that it will.
But it doesn't say when.
CHRIS BANES: OK, eventually.
Cool.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yep.
NICK BUTCHER: Next person?
Someone called the
Condor in Italy.
I made my first app for
a university course.
And my professor
said it's good.
But on Samsung device
it runs well.
And on HTCs it doesn't.
Is there a good way to test my
app on different devices?
DAVID: Emulators.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, I mean, I
think what he's trying to say
is for some reason his
app doesn't work on--
Samsung was it?
It works on Samsung
but not HTC.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, there's
a few things.
Samsung have their own online
test studio that you can use
if you become a Samsung
developer.
It's free for the first
x number of tests.
So go to Samsung Developer and
look for remote device access.
And then you can check
out devices.
You can say I want a note
two on firmware x.
And when it's available you get
to just go into your web
browser, upload your APK
and test it for free.
So for Samsungs it's
not too bad.
I don't if any of the other
Android OEMs that
provide that service.
NICK BUTCHER: I think Sony has
a system where you can get
real devices.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
Sony might have.
Outside of that, you'd
be looking at
a cloud-based service.
There are a number of
them out there.
They all charge for
their services.
NICK BUTCHER: Calabash,
Testdroid, DeviceAnywhere,
there's a bunch of them.
RICH HYNDMAN: Testdroid,
DeviceAnywhere, yeah.
These things.
So go to those websites.
Have a look.
Use our popular search
engine to find them.
And you should be able to find
good ways of uploading a test
script and having
it run across a
number of hardware devices.
And then you receive back the
log dumps, the screenshots,
all that kind of thing.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm interested why
he thinks it's a Samsung
versus HTC issue.
In my experience, comparing
similar devices across
manufacturers isn't really the
issue, performance wise.
It might be comparing Galaxy
S3 to HTC Wildfire or
something like that.
Then those are two very,
very differently
specced priced devices.
So I'd be interested in some
more details of what the
different devices were.
CHRIS BANES: And also, he didn't
mention whether they're
the same API levels.
So whether he's running on ice
cream sandwich versus jelly
bean or whatever.
NICK BUTCHER: Or like a
pre-hydroacceleration and post
hydroacceleration,
for example.
Yes a gingerbread versus jelly
bean, for example.
RICH HYNDMAN: Take a look at
your stats in the developer
console as well.
You'll be able to see what's
percentage of your installs
are on each of the API levels
since you're on each device,
that kind of thing.
That might help you break it
down and find out where the
issues are.
What anyone else thinks?
NICK BUTCHER: Another
good way--
going low tech on this-- is if
you join your local Android
user group.
This is certainly the way
we've seen before.
It's a good way to meet with
other Android developers, talk
Android chat.
But also to do a [? beach ?]
with them.
Say, hey, can you
guys run this?
And get a cross section
of devices and tell me
what's going on.
And you'll get some informed
people giving you feedback on
the performances and that.
And they'll probably give you
tips where they think you're
going wrong in your
code, as well.
DAVID: Yeah.
Free coffee, that's
all it costs.
Have them at the coffee shops.
RICH HYNDMAN: And be a good
citizen, offer to test their
apps out as well when they
need testing help.
Because testing apps on a wide
variety of handsets is really
helpfully done when it's
when it's distributed.
Is that [? Julien? ?]
He's just trying to sign on?
Oh no.
NICK BUTCHER: Or run like a
[INAUDIBLE] or something like
that, right?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
Yep.
Does anybody else who's just
joined us, or anybody else in
the Hangout have a
question for us?
NICK BUTCHER: Is Amit
in Hangout?
He was in and he left,
then he was in.
He's left.
OK.
He's asked a question which
I don't understand.
RICH HYNDMAN: Amit's there.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh,
you were here.
Did you ask your question?
Oh, you don't have
a microphone.
RICH HYNDMAN: He can
copy and paste
it in from the moderator.
NICK BUTCHER: Let's
watch him type.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
we could just.
RICH HYNDMAN: Fair enough.
So is this the question?
Other than the Android
development question.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Other than Android
development-- yeah,
he's placed it again.
Vote yes for this,
vote no for this.
Interesting.
CHRIS BANES: He's copied that.
RICH HYNDMAN: He's copied
quite a lot of it.
Let's go.
I'll just read it out.
Other than application
development, what are the
career opportunities in
Android or the Android
marketplace?
This is a question of a lot of
developers like me who want to
shift from other platforms
like Microsoft.
Application development,
obviously, is split down both
sides of writing your own
applications and writing
applications for other
companies are
clearly the two key ways.
And the most reliable income
always comes from writing
applications as a contractor or
consultant for other companies.
So that's the easiest way to
get into it until you're
confident enough and have the
ideas to start making your own
applications on the
side as well.
But there's a lot of companies
set up these days surrounding
the Play Store and Android.
There's companies with their
own application stores.
There's companies that do
publishing on behalf of other
applications, because a lot of
developers know how to write
applications, but don't how to
publish and market them.
So there's a lot of application
publishing
companies and marketing
companies
and advertising companies.
There's every single individual
part of the
ecosystem is taken care of.
NICK BUTCHER: Design,
tests, all sorts.
RICH HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
Yeah, even just the development
process.
CHRIS BANES: Test is a good
beginner side of it.
Because you get to see the
process of what software
development is from a less
technical side so you ease
yourself into it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
That's a good point.
I mean, we work with a
lot of partners here.
And we ask them how they
do their testing.
And some say, we just
outsource it.
It seems to be a pretty good
solution for getting
comprehensive tests done.
Just let the experts who do
testing across multiple
devices every day
do it for you.
And if you get into
that side of it.
Amit's just about to comment.
And say whether we've answered
his question or not, or
whether we totally
missed the pitch.
MATT GAUNT: Did we miss?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Oh, Amit says, good.
Thanks.
WIEBE ELSINGA: I think a good
graphics now makes it big.
Good graphics for
the marketplace.
To be able to come up and
say, this is going
to sell your app.
Or the eye catchers, or
something unique like that is
a big thing.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, I
think you're right.
CHRIS BANES: I agree.
I think design is really
important.
RICH HYNDMAN: Design is
really important.
[INAUDIBLE] some apps.
But yeah, there's more
developers than there are
designers at the moment.
People are now being able to
find Android developers to
make their apps, but being
able to get really good
designer can be tricky.
CHRIS BANES: Plus the market
has enough apps,
like enough OK apps.
It needs gorgeous apps.
RICH HYNDMAN: Nick's been saying
this saying this for
over a year now.
Make awesome apps.
He had it tattooed once, but
lasered off again of his face.
DAVID: I would love to
have a designer.
I do my stuff for free.
I would love to have someone
that's more into the design.
I've tried to do it.
But there's only a certain
amount of design.
You either have it
or you don't.
RICH HYNDMAN: I was
really lucky.
I mean, I got absolutely zero
design skills, and I had an
app that looked pretty bad.
I put it out there, and someone
offered to redesign it.
And I'm still building it,
but it looks absolutely
[INAUDIBLE].
I've ever come up with
a design as good as
Marie's did for mine.
CHRIS BANES: So there's two
good communities you
can go to on G+.
There's the Android design
official community.
And there's another one called
Android Designers, which is
invite only.
But just ask, and they'll let
you in unless you start
posting spam, in which
case you get banned.
But both are very, very
active communities.
And they have sections where
you can say, here's my app.
Any pointers?
And it's all very friendly.
And there's a section for asking
for people to help you
out with stuff.
So I'm not going to say they're
going to necessarily
design your app for free.
But they'll give you
some pointers.
RICH HYNDMAN: And Android user
groups are being far more
welcoming to designers
these days as well.
NICK BUTCHER: Or like Rich, you
might find-- you might be
lucky and find a designer who's
looking for a developer
so that they can increase their
portfolio or whatever,
to get more work.
Then they might just
take pity on you.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, then you
send them a developer who
takes six months to get the
designs realized and still
hasn't got them live.
But that was my fault because I
did a beta test, and so much
feedback came back that I
had to do improvements.
And then I took it to the
Android framework, and they
said you should have
done it that way.
All right, yeah.
There you go.
But it is open source,
so I'll fix it up.
CHRIS BANES: Yet again.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: David wants
a link to something.
I'm not quite sure what.
DAVID: Well, the link
to that group.
What was it?
RICH HYNDMAN: That's
Android Developers.
CHRIS BANES: Android
Designers.
RICH HYNDMAN: Sorry, Plus
Android Designers.
CHRIS BANES: I don't
think it is that.
RICH HYNDMAN: But is that-- if
you go to the Plus Android
Developers there should be the
communities down the side
there, right?
CHRIS BANES: So it comes with
the Android Designers, not
Android Design.
RICH HYNDMAN: And
where's that?
DAVID: I got it.
Never mind.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
Did you use the popular
search engine?
DAVID: Yeah, I used one
of the small ones.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: It's a lot
easier than asking us.
How's the moderator looking?
CHRIS BANES: I think we've
exhausted the moderator.
AUDIENCE: Hi guys.
I've got a question
if you want.
RICH HYNDMAN: Go for it.
AUDIENCE: It's a bit tricky.
But one of the requirements I've
got to look into is to do
with NFC card emulation mode.
I know that's heavily restricted
in Android.
I don't know if anyone's done
anything with [INAUDIBLE].
I've got some open card
emulation code.
Has anyone done anything
with that at all?
Or any experience?
Maybe from around the people
logged onto here as well?
CHRIS BANES: I haven't.
RICH HYNDMAN: No.
MATT GAUNT: I know what
you mean, but no.
I haven't.
RICH HYNDMAN: No, unfortunately
not.
Gone trivial.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
WIEBE ELSINGA: But you want
to emulate the NFC cards?
AUDIENCE: Yes I've got to do a
low-level NFC card emulation.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Because they
aren't that expensive.
I think for a buck you
can get an NFC tag.
AUDIENCE: Oh no, it's
a different
mode from tag reading.
It's a low-level way we send
back and forth messages to a
device or to a door reader.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you want to
replace one of these things on
your phone, they're
a cheap part.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, well thanks
anyway guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, at
least we can confirm
that it's not easy.
It's non trivial.
MATT GAUNT: Enjoy.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hope you haven't
committed to too much.
NICK BUTCHER: There's a good
blog with information on this
kind of stuff.
Do you know Nikolay Elenkov?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yes.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, you're
aware of his blog?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I've been
following that.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, he did some
really, really good low
down, low level what produces--
how all this works.
I think he talks about
how to do this on CN.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I need to get hold of
that guy, as well.
Thank you.
NICK BUTCHER: No worries.
RICH HYNDMAN: And we've got
another question, moderator.
From Alton.
What is a technical problem to
deploy a sandbox environment
and not been?
NICK BUTCHER: He's saying why
haven't we done it yet?
RICH HYNDMAN: Why haven't
we done it yet?
Yeah, don't know.
Yeah, why haven't
we done it yet?
That's a shame.
SAM: Thank you.
I've got a question.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's too bad you
have a question, but next one.
We've got one that says, what's
available on Android
devices if you don't publish
with Google Play Store?
Can you use GCM if you
haven't published
through the Play Store?
Yeah.
It just needs to be on a device
that has our suite of
services on it.
So you still need to be running
on a device that has
the Play Store even if you
didn't distribute your app
through the Play Store.
NICK BUTCHER: So when you're
developing your app from
before you publish it you
can still test it, GCM.
DAVID: And you can put
references to it, can't you?
Like you have to have
a dependency?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah it users
library, isn't it?
DAVID: Yeah so that it won't
install or whatever?
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
I think we may have exhausted
everything.
CHRIS BANES: We are.
RICH HYNDMAN: We're out of
questions and we [INAUDIBLE]
streams on the moderator.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Where is
Sparky, by the way?
RICH HYNDMAN: Sparky, last week,
he's transferred teams.
He's transitioned to an internal
team at Google now.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Hmm.
So he will not be joining
us again?
RICH HYNDMAN: No, he's
no longer in.
NICK BUTCHER: He may
pop his head in.
Head said he might pop his head
in every now and again.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, he
might pop his head in
from time to time.
He's still a good source of
Android knowledge for us.
But he's not in the Android
Develop Relations team
anymore, nope.
But he's still in the Munich
office, and he
still works for Google.
And he's on something
super cool.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Which you can't
say because of disclosure.
CHRIS BANES: Are you talking
about the laser beams?
RICH HYNDMAN: Whoa, dude.
Frigging laser beams.
MATT GAUNT: Laser beams coming
out of their heads.
SAM: Can I ask a question?
ALL: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, please do.
SAM: So I actually posted in
the moderator earlier under
Sam about the Google Maps API.
I don't think I was clear
enough, or I'm confused a
little bit.
So there is a way that I can
publish an app that can only
be accessed by a certain
organization in the Google
Play Store?
RICH HYNDMAN: I thought
you said not in
the Google Play Store?
SAM: Right, I did.
But I was confused.
Basically I want to create a
version of our app that only
our salespeople could use
for demo purposes.
RICH HYNDMAN: Absolutely, yes
you can do that if you're
using a Google Apps domain.
So if your company uses a Google
Apps domain to host its
infrastructure in any
way, your domain.
Then say you're at domino.com.
Then if you log into
the Android
device/Play Store, yeah.
Well, yeah, you're right.
You've got to go to the--
CHRIS BANES: You've got to
go to the Apps dashboard.
RICH HYNDMAN: The
Apps dashboard
first and turn it on.
SAM: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: And then you'll
get an extra square inside in
the Apps section of devices that
are logged in with on of
your domain accounts, which
is just your own internal
applications.
There was a blog post
about it just before
Christmas, I believe.
I can dig it out for you.
It was on the Android
developer's blog anyway.
SAM: All right, all right.
I can check that.
Yeah, the only issue I was
having is just if you use a
debug key, the maps don't show
up except for on the device
that you have plugged in.
And then if you use a production
key and try and
distribute the APK, the
app will crash when
you open it up, right?
Or am I mistaken?
Because I've tried to use a
production key and take that
APK and distribute it to some
of our salespeople.
And then when they open up the
app it crashes instantly.
CHRIS BANES: Have you
regenerated the maps from
using your distribution
key stopped working?
SAM: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, that
should be fine.
SAM: It should be fine?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, I've done
that a number of times without
uploading it to the
Play Store.
And with uploading it
to the Play Store.
SAM: So you're saying if I use
a production API key--
RICH HYNDMAN: Find the app with
the production API key,
and then go into the
Developer console.
And then use the production
API key when you get
your maps API key.
Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: So the Google
Maps key is tied to your
public key store that you
designed your app with?
SAM: Right.
CHRIS BANES: So if you're using
a debug key for Google
Maps but your release key for
your app, it won't work?
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, you can list
multiple key certificates
next to each API key
as well, right?
I think so.
If not, he can get both.
SAM: OK.
All right.
Well, thank you then.
RICH HYNDMAN: But you
can do both anyway.
You can have your own internal
apps inside the Play Store for
people on your own domain.
And you can create maps.
I did it using the new Maps.
But anyway, I haven't tried it
with the old Maps, Maps V2.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, I've only
tried with the old maps.
I've haven't used the new one.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, that's good.
I've only tried it with
the new maps.
So we're covered
SAM: All right.
Thanks a lot guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: All right.
Come back though, and re-post
in the thread if it doesn't
work for you, if you
find anything.
SAM: I will do that.
RICH HYNDMAN: Getting all the
ducks in a row to make it work
can be a little bit stressful
at times.
To get all the dev console stuff
and then the application
built properly.
SAM: OK, I'll figure it out.
Thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
CHRIS BANES: Check moderator.
RICH HYNDMAN: What
have we got?
Wiebe's posted something
into the chat.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Yeah, it's the
link for the private channel.
RICH HYNDMAN: Ah, that's what
it's called, Private Channel.
Thank you.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Yep.
CHRIS BANES: Questions.
MATT GAUNT: Hey, Timothy.
Got a question for us?
RICH HYNDMAN: So there's no
questions in the moderator.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
no questions.
RICH HYNDMAN: This might
be the shortest ever.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, me too.
If nothing else coming
in we'll let you
go and wrap up early.
We're going to start playing
with the format of this show,
as well, over the
next few weeks.
Try and make the output of it
more useful for people who are
watching it afterwards and
maybe formalize which
questions we'll be answering
during the show.
We just have to work out what's
best for you guys,
because I know the majority of
questions come in on the day
of the show.
CHRIS BANES: Like today.
RICH HYNDMAN: Because
that's obviously--
like today, yeah.
We had one question
before the show.
Now we've got 10.
Timothy has got a question.
Go on.
NICK BUTCHER: And we can also
go on the G+ thread as well.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, I
just found that.
CHRIS BANES: So while Timothy
types out his question, why
don't we go to the G+ thread?
RICH HYNDMAN: So since you have
a question for an app
product, so in-app billing
for offline functionality
TIMOTHY: Oh, that's how you--
RICH HYNDMAN: Hello?
TIMOTHY: Sorry I just realized
how to unmute.
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY: So it's my first
time on the Hangout.
RICH HYNDMAN: Welcome.
TIMOTHY: Yeah.
I asked a questions ages ago
on the moderator about
preventing swiping to views
on a ViewPager.
And I took your advice, Chris,
on preventing that by
controlling the adapter
and changing the size.
CHRIS BANES: OK, I can't
remember saying that, but I'll
agree with you.
TIMOTHY: OK.
[INAUDIBLE].
But yeah so it works for
all of each page
except the first one.
If there's just one view
displayed in a ViewPager, it
doesn't show that.
I'm after the feedback
that you get on
the right-hand side.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, the
force-field thing?
TIMOTHY: Yeah, that's it.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE].
So you can remind me what the
original requirement was?
TIMOTHY: OK, so the screen I'm
trying to do is I've got a
load of swipeable views.
And you can only progress to
the next view once you've
completed the first view.
Does that makes sense?
DAVID: It's a train.
RICH HYNDMAN: Sounds
like a wizard.
TIMOTHY: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
But I couldn't get it to prevent
the movement properly.
Or I could, but it was buggy.
So I tried your message,
Chris, and that worked.
But how do I trigger it so
that it would happen when
there's just one view
in the ViewPager?
CHRIS BANES: Don't intercept
any touch events.
Don't do anything.
Just let the ViewPager do it.
TIMOTHY: Really?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah because if
there's any [INAUDIBLE] in the
ViewPager it will handle
the edge effect anyway.
TIMOTHY: Right.
But I mean, I want to show the
user that they need to
complete something on the page
first so they can swipe.
Instead of having a CD like
Toast that says you need to
complete the thing first.
You need to complete
the form first.
How can I sort of--
CHRIS BANES: Control when
edge effect is shown?
TIMOTHY: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: So there's no real
easy way of doing that.
Other than taking the ViewPager
source into your
tree and hacking it.
Because edge effect isn't
exposed to you.
It's supposed to be something
that's transparent to the
user, and to the developer.
TIMOTHY: OK.
So even if we want to change
the color as well.
Is that also going to need?
CHRIS BANES: It's all
done on Drawable.
So you'd have to
do it yourself.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: Not that
I can remember.
It's all down on Drawable.
NICK BUTCHER: No,
I don't think.
CHRIS BANES: Well,
I don't know.
I can't remember.
But I don't think you can.
TIMOTHY: OK.
CHRIS BANES: As a quick
thing, Roman Nurik has
released his Wizard.
TIMOTHY: Oh, the WizardPager.
Yeah, I'll have a
look at that.
CHRIS BANES: And that' a really
good example of how to
do this nicely.
So have a look at that and
see how he's done it.
TIMOTHY: OK thanks a lot guys.
CHRIS BANES: Cheers.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, let's
grab that one out of
the G+ stream, then.
MATT GAUNT: Yep so, in-app
billing for offline
functionality, how can I make
sure the user has access for
some function on my app if its
functionality is dependent on
in-app billing?
So essentially, if they want to
charge for a certain aspect
of an app, but the user isn't
online, how can you still
essentially charge them and
give them access to it?
CHRIS BANES: If they're
not online?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, you
can't charge them
if they're not online.
And your app should clearly
cache whether or not it's
being purchased or not.
CHRIS BANES: Well, you should
be able to restore
transactions and it'll cache.
RICH HYNDMAN: But if
you're not online--
I know we have the cached
Play store.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, so if you're
using the V3, via
[INAUDIBLE] it's all cached
anyway for you.
So there's no real
need to cache.
It does that itself.
RICH HYNDMAN: Depends on if he
wanted to recall Restore
Transactions, or something
like that.
MATT GAUNT: So imagination
John's just trying to
essentially store the
transaction if it didn't, and
then kick it off in advance in
the future but [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: The thing is,
you can't force the user.
If you want to kick it off again
in the future you can't
force them to actually
go through with it.
So you give it to
them for free.
So yeah, it all depends on
your business model.
But you probably wanted to wait
until they go back online
before you actually
give them access.
DAVID: Yeah, how does that work
with in-app purchases?
Say you're buying some
gold coins to
get to the next level.
And then you're not connected,
and then you're like oh, I got
to the next level.
[CHUCKLES]
DAVID: There's a lot of code
you have to do too.
ALL: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Well, you've got
simplified in V3 right?
So it's all synchronized.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
V3 helped a lot with that.
It is synchronous and the
Play Store does cash the
transactions.
NICK BUTCHER: So basically
if it doesn't
succeed, then don't progress.
Don't unlock the content.
RICH HYNDMAN: Just tell the
user to return online.
Hopefully it's an [INAUDIBLE]
the user online.
Or the users that aren't online
understand why they
can't purchase something.
OK anything else come in?
CHRIS BANES: We had somebody
new join us.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh yeah,
anybody else in the
Hangout have a question?
CHRIS BANES: It doesn't
look like it.
MATT GAUNT: We've got some more
questions on the G+ thread.
CHRIS BANES: A bunch
more, go for it.
MATT GAUNT: All my
techs use SP.
But one user asked for
text size options.
What exactly does she want?
Isn't there an option
in the settings to
change the font size?
And this is from Caitlin,
I think
So yeah, generally the whole
point of SP is so that it
acknowledges the system-wide
text size preference.
Chances are the user's used an
app where the app itself
actually has additional text
sizes, as in, say, I want to
increase the size large,
medium, or small.
And that could be related to the
system font size as well.
So I imagine that's what
it's asking for.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
it's quite common.
You see it in news reading apps
and something like that.
They'll quite commonly have a
text size option that you bump
it up a little bit if
you feel like it.
So I guess that's what the
user is requesting.
So yeah, the answer you could
say, is hey, go to Settings
and change the setting.
RICH HYNDMAN: If they don't want
to change the font size
for their entire device, and
they just want to change it in
your application-- and that's
fair enough, I can understand
why, especially if you've chosen
particularly small
fonts-- but yeah, there
are obviously options.
MATT GAUNT: So think about
it, whether it makes
sense for your app?
Whether you think it's
a common use case.
It might not be.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: You can always
use magnification as well.
Whatever that three-finger
tap is.
[INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: Adds
accessibility.
MATT GAUNT: That's
a good location.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
So unless there's anything
coming in from Moderator I
think we've exhausted all the
questions in this chatter.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK guys.
I think we might be done
for this week.
NICK BUTCHER: No, there's
one more.
RICH HYNDMAN: Aw, every time.
That's the third time
I've said that.
Now it's not the
shortest ever.
It's soon to be the
longest ever.
WIEBE ELSINGA: David, the movie,
was it Open Garden?
DAVID: Yeah.
And I've been looking for it
during this show, and they cut
it out of their recorded
video.
I was watching it live.
WIEBE ELSINGA: OK, I got
the internet site.
DAVID: Yeah, so Open Garden
stopped doing the NFC and
they're just doing the
Bluetooth only for
communicating.
And that's where they open up
a VPN tunnel between all the
different devices.
And they measure the output, and
they share the bandwidth
between them.
So if another device comes on,
and that says it's connected
to Wi-Fi, or if it's using
HSPA or whatever, they'll
share bandwidth and
go back and forth.
If only one has it,
they'll all do it.
And since it's a VPN tunnel it
only looks like it's coming
from that device.
OK.
NICK BUTCHER: The extra
question is
just London, the moderator.
It's from The Condor again, who
asks might be the right
place, but is it an
opportunity to do
internships in Europe?
I'm guessing with Google
as a user experience.
So I don't think anyone
here knows that.
I think if you go to--
RICH HYNDMAN: They're all
on google.com/jobs.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, go
to google.com/jobs.
And go to the internship
section.
They'll have all the details.
I don't know where the
internships land, but there
certainly is user experience
in Android done in Europe.
So it's entirely possible.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE] is
out of the question in the
chat stream.
So I have one question.
If we extend application class
sometimes when we clear the
activities from the stack by
pressing the back button, and
we then launch the app,
sometimes the last instance of
the application class
is still there.
But the application object stays
alive for as long as the
process is alive.
So it's a singleton.
So yeah, there's not much else
to say other than that really.
I'd wonder why you're
trying to--
why this is affecting
your app.
Because if the state you're
trying to keep is specific to
an activity then there shouldn't
be any activity on
the application.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, as long
as their case [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: So only keep global
stuff that you don't
care the lifetime of, really,
in an application.
So stuff like caches, and
that kind of stuff.
WIEBE ELSINGA: You can always
empty the back stack.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, I think the
question's more about why,
sometimes, the application
keeps
alive and why it doesn't.
So when you press Back.
NICK BUTCHER: So let's say
what you're reporting is
expected behavior.
But yeah, it's probably that
it doesn't work as you
imagined it works.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Back
isn't Close.
Back is always the same problem
when you talk to
Android developers starting with
the difference between
the Home and the Back button,
and they think the activity's
closed when you put
Back or Home.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, sure.
RICH HYNDMAN: Mm-hmm.
DAVID: You should have to
watch a video when you
download the APK of
the life cycle.
RICH HYNDMAN: I love
that idea.
VIGNESH: What I think is--
RICH HYNDMAN: Ooh.
Is that Vignesh?
VIGNESH: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: I can't
hear you.
RICH HYNDMAN: Sorry.
MATT GAUNT: Can you speak up?
Maybe bring the microphone
closer?
VIGNESH: I was just asking if
I have stack of activities,
and [INAUDIBLE]
cookies from the stack.
And when all the duties
are cleared, my
application gets closed.
And then I relaunch
the application.
It stems off my last pack.
It stems off application
clause-- it's still there.
I mean, when I come back, the
[INAUDIBLE] which I assigned
previously to the application
object are still there.
RICH HYNDMAN: That's right,
that's correct.
NICK BUTCHER: Correct.
Yeah, that's production
as expected.
VIGNESH: OK, that's
expected behavior?
ALL: Yeah.
VIGNESH: Oh, thanks.
DAVID: That's so that when
you launch the app
again it's in the cache.
It's faster next time.
Isn't that correct?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, Android will
do things to try and keep
activities and applications
around.
And it'll only kill them when
it's got memory pressures.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, so if you
actually need to force those
values to reset, just grab
them when [INAUDIBLE]
or somewhere further
down the life cycle
and reset them yourself.
[? Ulya ?] has joined
us, apparently.
[? ULYA: ?]
Oh yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah?
Well, this Hangout was going
to finish 20 minutes ago
because we ran out
of questions.
But then it just kept
on just surviving.
[? ULYA: ?]
You guys got so much good
stuff to share.
How can it stop?
Just a quick question
for Matt.
MATT GAUNT: Hi.
[? ULYA: ?]
Anymote Protocol, is
that open sourced?
MATT GAUNT: So we've open
sourced the libraries that
we're using for Android.
You can also find it--
there's a library for it.
There's also just a plain
Java library.
I can't remember who did it.
I'll dig it out for you, but
there's an Anymote library
which is just purely Java.
It doesn't rely on any Android
side of things.
The actual Google TV
implementation, I don't think
is open sourced.
I think that's kept in house.
So yeah, I think it's only the
actual use of protocol that's
open sourced.
[? ULYA: ?]
OK, cool.
I'll let you guys get to your
Google cups of coffee now.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT GAUNT: Got to
love that coffee.
RICH HYNDMAN: All right.
What's that?
Oh, Lindon's saying he
had an [? Ulya ?]
demo room at the Melbourne
Android
developer Meetup tonight.
Excellent.
That's funny.
Because he's in Melbourne.
Tonight's already happened.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, had.
RICH HYNDMAN: Had, already
had one tonight.
NICK BUTCHER: Gotcha.
CHRIS BANES: There's one
more that's come
through on the Google+.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: What
does it say?
MATT GAUNT: What are the
drawbacks of using config
changes orientation on activity
to prevent it from
recreating after screen
orientation change?
The only one I've found is that
I cannot use different
layout for landscapes.
There's nothing else.
RICH HYNDMAN: That's
the main one.
But you can.
You can call Request
Layout anyway.
So it's not going
to automatically
process it for you.
CHRIS BANES: You can do.
But it also has to do
with the Action bar.
So the Action bar has got
optimizations in Landscape
where it gets slightly smaller,
which won't happen if
you override the
configuration.
But if you call Request
Layout, will it?
NICK BUTCHER: I think it will.
RICH HYNDMAN: Really?
CHRIS BANES: I don't know,
but I think it will.
But I could be wrong though.
RICH HYNDMAN: So we're starting
to see video apps and
things working this way, that
they have the video playing
and you certainly don't want
to restart the video or
interrupt the video when
you rotate it.
So they'll do the orientation
change themselves and then
request layout but keep the
video playing inside the
little video play window.
And yeah I don't
think there's--
as Chris says.
OK is that it?
NICK BUTCHER: And well,
also, it depends on
what your logic is.
Because if you're depending on
getting your unpause and then
unresume, cool, it's
just kind of like,
manage your states somehow.
Then that's obviously not
going to get called--
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
you're right.
You're in custom views.
NICK BUTCHER: So be
careful of that.
And any frame which
might be using--
CHRIS BANES: And the retain
configuration state, whatever
it's called.
Is a bit decrepit now.
So you shouldn't really
rely on it.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
MATT GAUNT: We're
actually done.
RICH HYNDMAN: We're going to go
for the button, We're going
to end the broadcast.
There's nothing else
coming in.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ULYA: You know, every time Rich
wraps on the session,
everybody take a shot.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: That's
10 shots today.
All right, cheers guys,
thanks for joining us.
DAVID: Thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: Goodnight.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Bye.
RICH HYNDMAN: Goodnight
everyone.